where did you grow up in Atlanta Georgia
Atlanta Georgian I'm Atlanta Georgia and
I'm not proud it's hot Lana baby we
talking about strippers with big booties
homie was talking about Magic City who
me that's why she's in California I
think yeah her souls always been a
California girl I think so and my voice
has always been a valley girl and like
everyone talks like me and like a basic
[ __ ] is easier did a lot of pretty
people on that Lana though yeah but you
moved to LA [ __ ] the [ __ ] the area that
I grew up in was such a secluded area
and I grew up in such a community that
was very opposing anything that wasn't
like them and so like last I think last
month I went to Lana oh my god was it
last month I could not like I was
shaking in Atlanta why I have such a
strong like negative emotion associated
with the place that I was raised that
when I go back like I physically feel
sick and like why were you like bullied
and [ __ ] yeah but I mean like everybody
was so you know depending on what type
of bullying it was I mean yeah I did it
can bring back some bad memories and
[ __ ] yeah I mean there was some intense
ones I think it was mainly like I was
bullied by really unfortunate people
okay that sounded wrong so I was bullied
by like church leaders myself you really
shouldn't be bullied by church leaders
Korean churches I heard can be a little
bit difficult this is not all churches
obviously but no but it's I think as
Japanese and Korean culture is very
similar we have amazing there's a high
yeah there's a there's a fine line
between hazing and bullying and
sometimes it gets overboard yeah but
it's also rite of passage yeah in our
culture which is kind of bad and toxic
but it happens because I when I started
making Chinese friends I was like oh
thank god I could breathe I can [ __ ]
breathe
exactly what you're talking about get
amis Chinese they don't [ __ ] bull you
the way that we do know so it's like oh
my god and I don't have to [ __ ] in this
guy's two years older than me but it's
fine
oh my god thank god he's not giving me a
[ __ ] wedgie yeah for sure yeah
it was nuts no my pastors this is not an
emotional topic guys okay because I have
learned I have progressed I am new again
I am still a ho so no when I was in high
school obviously like you fall into like
bad habits sometimes bad influences and
I ended up losing my virginity for the
first time and it was a very traumatic
experience I did not love it you know
but who does and then I told my pastor's
wife because I was like I can confide in
her she seems like you know condemns you
didn't she she she acted there's not a
drink of emotional water it's let me
tell you cotton mouth okay do this so I
confided in her and like the way that I
did it wasn't like oh yeah matter of
fact this happened it was like hey I
feel really like confused you know I
don't know like am I gonna go to hell
like what's happening I want to live
should I tell my mom and so I confided
like that in at first she's like very
understanding she's like no I mean thank
you for telling me blah blah blah and
then she's like why don't we go out
we're gonna get all the girls together
and we're just gonna talk things through
you don't have to talk about you know
what happened to you but we're just
gonna all talk about it we open
conversation and so we go into the room
this was Sunday and all the girls are in
there and I feel like everyone new is
kind of about me because I was already
like crying at that point and she has
this giant roll of like [ __ ] Costco
size kitchen size aluminum foil and she
hands out of sheets every girl right and
she's like it's beautiful it's shiny
it's shimmery look at it in the light
blah blah poetic [ __ ] and then um she
crumbles it and she's like now everybody
crumble it this is Stephanie yeah she's
like crumbling so I crumbled mine
everybody's crumbling there's and then
she goes okay now try to get it back to
where it was and then so we're all
unfolding it we're doing that thing
against like the table
where we're trying to like yeah then
she's like it'll never be the same
that's your virginity taken away pretty
much you know why you little fatty
[ __ ] I'm sorry just kidding should
probably not have I apologize though
yeah but that is so rude it hold were
you I was in high school so she was
making an example out of you yeah
everyone knew and guess what everyone
mmm-hmm well you know one of us here
crumbled ass piece of 40 ya know the
[ __ ] crazy thing about that [ __ ] is
is like you guys didn't have to realize
like I grew up in a church my father's a
pastor I was a youth minister you there
are so many people and this is not to
represent the whole religion I don't
like doing blanket statements like that
but what happens with a lot of
individuals is like they are track
pieces of trash themselves so they have
to try to bring somebody else down to
make them feel better about how
something and it happens a lot in
churches too because there's not Christ
it's this whole fear of like they almost
want to highlight somebody else's shame
to hide bears right so and I guarantee
you to like dude there are so many
people that want the church just for
[ __ ] [ __ ] man like this Bishop I'm
telling you man straight up dude there
was a bunch of [ __ ] thugs that came
to church because they wanted to [ __ ]
every Church girl and guess what they
[ __ ] them but these were the same
[ __ ] girls that were there at every
Bible study talking about I'm still a
[ __ ] virgin does a [ __ ]
I saw a picture of you sucking his dick
like what are you talking about [ __ ]
ho but they had the audacity and the
gall to go up in front of everybody and
talk about how important it is to keep
their virginity let me tell you
something [ __ ] another crazy [ __ ]
right so I know there's other other girl
actors like former YouTube or some [ __ ]
right and mind you I know about her
specifically because I know guys that
have [ __ ] her right and they know
about her like crazy tendencies so you
know word gets around real easy
especially with [ __ ] Korean people
they they [ __ ] talk everybody's ears
off so we were at this [ __ ] gala
event and she was there hey and this
[ __ ] is so [ __ ] funny man like I'm
sitting there and mind you I know one of
my best friends is the gut he used to
hook up with her all the [ __ ] time
and that we're sitting and we're eating
and she's behind me and I hear her
talking and she goes she's talking to
another girl she goes yeah I'd like I
don't really believe in sex before
marriage she goes like I think it's
completely okay for
the weight and I [ __ ] spat my drink
out I was [ __ ] 1970 spit-take oh [ __ ]
and the funny thing is that girl never
asked her if she was a virgin she just
voluntarily put that information now she
goes all I'm a virgin
[ __ ] ass [ __ ] ho nobody asked you
with your loose ass [ __ ] like nobody
[ __ ] it but I'm saying like and she
is like one of those holier-than-thou
people talks about oh man I'm this
church leader I love doing praise
because I want to put God first it's
like yo man you could say whatever you
want and if you really are Christian and
you do believe that God is really this
omnipotent being you could lie to
everybody in this room but you ain't
lying to God so what's the whole point
you know crazy though I'm telling you
crazy you know I can't believe some she
actually did that [ __ ] you know what to
be honest with you it's kind of funny
from the kitchen she thought of this she
did and she's like that's a good one
just like I would I wish I went to that
church I would call everybody god I've
been like [ __ ] Esther I know you suck
this guy's grace I know you suck in
John's dick I know you did it right
behind the [ __ ] Pew you [ __ ]
[ __ ] ass ho Jenny don't even act like
you don't [ __ ] watch porn I know you
you've been masturbating I smelled your
fingers [ __ ] honey I know what's up
all you [ __ ] dirty ass [ __ ] I
don't like it when people is so funny
because that's like the most fun
christ-like thing to do it's just sit
and then judge other people for their
sins because it's like the worse I mean
and what is she learning from that
exactly it's like okay so your virginity
is gone so you committed this diabolical
sin now what now what the [ __ ] are you
supposed to do hey everyone let's rub it
in each other's like let's rub it in her
face that she just lost her virginity
did she call you out or she just made
you but like I mean I feel like
everybody has like what is it called in
English like Newton see like yeah yeah I
mean you know it's about me I'm like the
only one with bloodshot tears we were
talking prior tall I think all the other
girls were virgins too why no that one
of them were
exactly yeah I would have called
everybody outside as your aluminum foil
not crumpled big where they all
afterwards was there a point like did
they get together and talk about they're
losing the virginity or anything it was
just like symbolism yeah it's like
similar you are crumbled poet spoiled
that's that's all you are
that's so funny because even that right
there is very unchristian like there's
nothing in the Bible that says that once
you're tainted guy will never love you
so what in the [ __ ] are you talking
about [ __ ] you are gonna be the first
person to go to hell and God's God's
gonna have a [ __ ] piece of aluminum
foil and he's gonna pass it to your
Korean ass anybody crumple it my child
that's you and he's gonna throw it down
to [ __ ] waste bags that go straight to
hell and she's gonna go right there to
it's so funny that she was thinking so
hard for what symbolism works and she
came out with foil it's kind of genius
it is genius because it did stick with
me for a hot second and I completely
went I mean I don't know if she did this
on purpose I mean you might have to note
right but like I completely after that I
was like done with Church I was like I'm
gonna go hang out with these kids who
are like the opposite of Church but then
the funny thing is like I'm sitting
there okay what are we doing here
crumbling the foil okay we're trying to
get it back to normal like and then she
goes that your virginity I wouldn't even
do this if this is what you're gonna do
dude yeah was she was she married yeah
she was that pastor is also going to
hell today she's completely cheating
that I know it I those are yeah and it's
such as Jezebel way of doing things
about that sucks too that you actually
trusted her enough to confide in and she
[ __ ] threw it in your face like
backstabber you [ __ ] come back I hope
you're watching this right now if I ever
[ __ ] see you in the middle of the
street I'm kicking you in your [ __ ] I'm
doing a [ __ ] upper [ __ ] on your ass
why is it that there are more Satan's in
church then there are Jesus's they call
Church the hospital for the sick and you
know it's like people like that are the
ones who need Church the most it's just
that it's got it though so it's like the
Saints running Church it sucks because
they don't get called out on that [ __ ]
but that's why people never like me in
church I call that you know with a quick
I'd be like you don't do that [ __ ] it
was I think that's one of the reasons
why I left a church - cuz I loved going
there seeing my friends eating like but
the way that they were bullying my mom
your mom yeah cuz you know what's crazy
they bullied my mom to like well that
was the problem kid so like like the
same situation it was easy for them to
be like look at that family look at them
how unchristian like instead of getting
together and helping and it's like it's
more like let's ridicule them and then
pray for them and talk [ __ ] about them
and man it was my other family members
too like they were going through a hard
time and they they looked at the church
for help and then they said hey we need
to borrow some money and they all looked
at him as if like they're trying to scam
them and but they gave so much to the
church they gave so much to other people
and when they needed help it they looked
at him as if like you're just trying to
scam us I'll pray for you
that's freaking nuts it is right okay on
the topic of firing money have you guys
ever met friends money I don't believe
in lending money
I believe that my freshers suffered no
and that's our case I've done it I don't
I don't lend money I give money so what
I mean by that is that my father always
told me since I was younger he goes if
you have enough money and you're
financially stable enough to give
somebody money that means you're also
financially stable enough not to ask for
it back so if you're in a situation
where you go house Christian like if
you're in a situation where you give
money and then you're worried about your
own savings account don't give that
money on the first place he goes just
tell them that you can't help them out
but if you can't give it out that means
that you are acknowledging the choice
that you may never see that money again
because it makes friendship weird yeah
so no no I I want it to be weird
uncomfortableness no I like it
you know why anymore okay so check this
out I used to [ __ ] test people all
the time because I wanted to see their
character I loved seeing people's true
character right so like if people ask me
for money I keep tabs I want to make
sure that this person is honorable or
else why am i spending time being this
person's friend so you have like a whole
ice booklet of like